welcome back to twisting Pine Homestead
you know when you think of
homesteading uh you might picture
Grandma's homemade jam and Grandpa's
woodworking projects but get this in
2024 yeah it's not just Grandma and
Grandpa getting back to the land it's
actually younger Generations leading the
homesteading charge wow yeah imagine
growing your own food raising livestock
mastering DIY skills could you be a
modern Homesteader it really is
fascinating to see how this trend is
playing out it's not just Nostalgia trip
there are some very real reasons why
people especially Millennials and gen Z
are embracing this lifestyle okay so
let's dive into those reasons our
sources highlight a growing concern
about food quality okay many people are
worried about what's in their food the
pesticides the processing they're
craving healthier more sustainable
options and growing your own produce
gives you that control you know exactly
what's going into your food and you can
ensure it's organic and free of harmful
chemicals that makes sense plus let's be
honest with grocer prices skyrocketing
right growing your own food and raising
livestock could save a significant
amount of money in the long run that's
right homesteading can offer a level of
financial Independence especially
appealing to younger Generations facing
economic challenges it's a way to take
control of your budget and become more
resilient but it's not just about
practicality is it no our sources
suggest there's a deeper environmental
Consciousness driving this movement
definitely we're seeing a growing
awareness of the environmental impact of
our lifestyle choices homesteading
offers a way to reduce waste conserve
resources and minimize our carbon
footprint I can see how that aligns with
the values of many younger people but
you know one thing that surprised me is
the emphasis on the mental and emotional
benefits of homesteading absolutely
gardening caring for animals being
connected to Nature these activities can
be incredibly therapeutic in a world
that's constantly demanding our
attention homesteading offers a chance
to slow down reconnect with the natural
rhythms of life and find a sense of
Peace so we've got these practical
concerns about food and finances the
desire for sustainability and this
yearning for a simpler more connected
life but how does this fit into the
larger picture of societal Trends well
one thing to consider is the rise of
remote work the shift has given people
more flexibility to live and work
wherever they choose making rural living
and homesteading a viable option for
many who wouldn't have considered it
before so it's not just a change in
mindset but a change in lifestyle that's
making this possible precisely
and there's also a growing rejection of
excessive consumerism people are looking
to downsize declutter and focus on
experiences rather than material
possessions when our source described it
as a shift from Fast fashioned and
disposable culture to a more mindful
approach to consumption with an emphasis
on quality over quantity choosing
handmade goods and things that are truly
useful exactly and along with that comes
a desire for authenticity and connection
people are longing for a sense of
community a connection to the land in a
life that feels more genuine and
purposeful our sources painted a v
picture of this slower pace of life on a
homestead where you can Savor the fruits
of your labor and feel a deep sense of
satisfaction from providing for yourself
and your family it's a sense of purpose
that many crave yes and that sense of
purpose can be hard to find in the
modern world where we're often
disconnected from the tangible results
of our work homesteading offers a way to
reconnect with that Primal instinct to
create nurture and build something with
your own hands it'sing amazing to see
how people are blending traditional
practices with modern Innovations to
make this lifestyle possible we read
about solar panels rainwater collection
systems permaculture Gardens all these
things that allow people to thrive off
grid even in remote locations it really
is a testament to human Ingenuity it
makes you wonder what aspects of
homesteading appeal to you is it the
idea of fresh homegrown food the
financial Independence the desire to
reconnect with nature or maybe it's the
challenge of learning new skills and
becoming more self-sufficient and
thinking bigger picture how might this
lifestyle shift impact communities could
we see a Revival of rural areas as more
people Embrace homesteading these are
all fascinating questions to consider as
we see this Resurgence of interest in
homesteading it's clear that
homesteading offers a path to
self-sufficiency sustainability and
personal fulfillment it's about taking
control of your food your resources and
ultimately your life and it's about
finding a deeper connection to the land
and to ourselves it's about slowing down
appreciating the simple things and
building resilience in a world that's
constantly changing I think that
resonates with a lot of people
especially in today's world could hom
setting even on a small scale be a way
to find greater meaning in a world that
often feels overwhelming and
disconnected what do you think I think
it's certainly a possibility even small
steps like growing a few herbs on your
window sill or learning to can your own
Tomatoes can bring a sense of
accomplishment and connection and those
small steps could lead to bigger things
and one of our sources mentioned a
family who started with just a small
vegetable garden and ended up
transforming their entire lifestyle
they're now raising chickens goats and
even bees it's amazing how one small
change can have a ripple effect and
there are so many resources available to
help people get started even if they
don't have a lot of land or experience
speaking of resources social media
platforms like Tik Tok are playing a
huge role in making homesteading more
accessible you can find tutorials on
everything from building a chicken coup
to fermenting your own vegetables it's
really democratizing the knowledge and
skills needed to embrace this lifestyle
and it's inspiring to see so many people
sharing their Journeys and supporting
each other online it really does create
a sense of community and that's
something that's often missing in our
modern Digital World absolutely
homesteading is about more than just
self-sufficiency it's about connecting
with others who share your values and
passions it's about building a network
of support and learning from each
other's experiences and who knows maybe
it could even lead to a Revival of rural
areas as more people choose to live
closer to the land and embrace a more
sustainable lifestyle it's certainly a
possibility at worth exploring there are
so many benefits to rural living from
fresh air and Open Spaces to a slower
pace of life and a strong sense of
community I think it's safe to say that
homesteading is more than just a trend
it's a movement that's gaining momentum
and it's exciting to see how it's
evolving and adapting to the needs of
Modern Life it's a reminder that we have
the power to create a more sustainable
and fulfilling way of life both for
ourselves and for future Generations
well we've covered a lot of ground today
and I think we've just scratched the
surface of this fascinating topic but
before we wrap up we'd love to hear from
you what aspects of homesteading
resonate most with you what challenges
do you anticipate and how do you think
this lifestyle could impact communities
in the future share your thoughts with
us on social media and let's continue
this conversation and if you're enjoying
this deep dive into home setting be sure
to like share and subscribe to Twisted
Pine Homestead your support helps us
keep bringing you these fascinating
conversations and hey if you're feeling
extra generous you can even buy us a
coffee we appreciate every single one of
you and as always thank you for
listening to Twisted Pine Homestead
we'll see you next time for another Deep
dive into the world of sustainable
living happy homesteading everyone and
hey if you're feeling extra generous you
can even buy us a coffee we appreciate
every single one of you and as always
thank you for listening to Twisted Pine
Homestead we'll see you next time for
another deep dive into the world of
sustainable living happy homesteading
everyone